Ashley I is back on bachelor in paradise  and all she can do is cry don't cry cry  ass they returned for another shot at  love but revealed she's still all hung  up on Jarrod who had fallen for Kayla  and according to Ashley Kayla had  promised her off-camera that she would  not be coming to Paradise I didn't know  that I was coming I decided like two  days before  so what happened to the whole like he's  done right you're tight yikes that only  left one thing for Ashley to say double  yikes here's what Jared told me in June  about how things turn out for him are  you in love do you fall in love and  paradise I got lucky enough to meet some  wonderful girls in Paradise I feel like  I'm in a good place right now so whose  side are you on here Ashley's or Kayla's  let me know on Twitter